et pas une chose c'est que les mains
inspiratrice et la mort
si vous mettez pas votre peau sur la
table vous n'avez rien il faut payer
louis ferdinand céline est un écrivain
mythique du 20e siècle et la légende
voulait qu'il se soit fait voler
plusieurs manuscrits ils ont été
retrouvés près de 60 ans après sa mort
bon c'est une histoire magique enfin
voilà qui est on rêverait tous de vivre
d'autres épisodes la disparition de 5324
feuillets remonte à juin 1944 l'auteur
du chef-d'oeuvre voyage au bout de la
nuit avaient fui paris à la libération
parce qu'il craignait d'être jugé pour
ses propos antisémites et
collaborationniste son appartement de la
rue girardon avaient été pillés et
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie l'écrivain dira
qu'il s'était fait voler on m'a tout
volé mon jeu tantôt juste une petite
misère on a tous pris on se disait
toujours qu'elle est la part de vrai
quelle est la part de fo là dedans est
ce que c'est encore une provocation de
céline voilà non la vérité c'est que il
disait vrai il disait vrai les
manuscrits cacher avait été remis au
début des années 2000 à un critique du
journal libération avec promesse de ne
rien dévoiler avant la mort de lucette
destouches la veuve de céline à la mort
de celle-ci en 2019 le critique révèle
l'existence des feuillets lycée lignée
dont barnabé wesley jubile c'est un
événement inouï et sans précédent dans
l'histoire littéraire aujourd'hui on
parle d'un mètre cube de manuscrits et
ce ne sont pas des manuscrits de fonds
de tiroirs des lettres ou des choses
déjà publiées
le livre regards écrit probablement en
1934 est le premier livre à être tirées
de cette découverte il est la pièce
manquante entre les romans voyage au
bout de la nuit est mort à crédit une
révélation pour biz admirateurs de
l'oeuvre c'est comme
fan des beatles qui découvrirait un
nouvel album des beatles c'est aussi
important il nous raconte l'horreur de
la guerre il ya des passages magnifique
où il dénonce là il dit d'ailleurs j'ai
commencé le livre avec ce géant fermer
la gare dans ma tête tellement il a reçu
d'explosion il y aura gardé toute sa vie
des acouphènes qu'ils auront rendu fou
littéralement pas chez dormait le plus
grand écrivain du monde c'est louis
ferdinand céline des écrivains comme
jack kerouac et réjean ducharme ont été
de grands lecteurs de louis ferdinand
céline mais l'homme derrière l'écrivain
divise le public car il a tenu dans des
pamphlets des propos antisémites
inexcusable je fais toute ma vie lui
reprocher ce qui le dit ce qu'il ne fait
jamais excusé toutes ces horreurs
antisémite infondées d'ailleurs mais par
contre je suis capable de reconnaître le
plaisir qu'ils me donnent quantique en
tant que je lis dans ce roman qui vient
de paraître il n'y a absolument
aucune mention des juifs ce qui compte
c'est l'objet guerre s'est écoulé à près
de 200000 exemplaires en france
gallimard compte publier trois autres
livres à partir du feuillet retrouvés au
cimetière d'el ont réagi à meudon
l'écrivain et médecin louis ferdinand
céline doit se retourner dans sa tombe
lui qui condamnait la lourdeur de
l'homme nous verrons si un jour une
révolte d'esprit contre contre contre le
poids mais c'est pas pour demain ici
louis fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal